なぜだよ夏みんな動きたいでないよね僕も値動き足りないんだよね
結局ね粗茶はが夏らから汗かいちゃうだから僕はにできればで結局猫のつれ慣れない
動き食べないんだよねそうなっちゃうんだよな結局な結果的になったら今日は動き足り
ない日々たちに朗報です
マジックハンドアップしてますこ
かあさんご参加ちゃんとから伸びる腕があるんです
伸びるでマジックハンドって言うんですけどでもなお店に売ってるのはな
結局な小さいんでなくそうなっちゃうんだよなお茶だからなんだから今日はね
コース張ってでもいろんなものをね動かずに取れるぐらいバカでかいマジックハンドを
作ろうと思いますまじかーーんね割
足で作れるんだよ
小さい頃にやった覚えが分かります320本準備したんですー
まあこの割り箸を使ってな超長いねマジックハンドをつくってな
俺はね夏はデコったら動かないことでしたよこうしてこのあのはずのマジックハンドで
いろんなものを取る
ご飯をトレース気概もトレイです充実も取れるし
まあ署名は失禁だなこれ誰でも作れると思うからね
ぜひな3
7結局な真似しちゃうんだよなそうなっちゃうんだよな
コロッケていきますえっとまずはマジックハンド本体を組み立てます
貼る場所4前を重ねればもんで留めます互い違いに10時になるようにしてください
こういうことだなこういう感じがこういう感じが
コードこれはもういいセット付
ということができましたここをつけるこういう感じだな
動く告げるということ
おこういう感じだ ok ok ok
わかりましたこれを後312前あるんで生産に312前あるんで全部繋げてね
商店街の作ろうと思います
これたぶん早受ける人もつまんないから一気にバンッ
10分がいたってここらへんまできました
全然年池そんなんですよね
取得やってなっちゃうよね梅雨期なんですよねぇ
[音楽]
けどなぁなんか服似合ってなっちゃうんですよ
多分長さだけじゃダメですね我が社団2巻にしてマジックハンド時代強化していきます
4重構造にしました
これなら全然余裕でしょ
もうちょっと進めていきましたーーー
しんどいかなこれ動いた方は絶対よ
作ってから後悔するパターン
よっしゃできたこんな感じになりました
ペットボトルのキャップをつけるとこうパックパークできるわけです
よしそれで
つかめるわけですキャンプで被ってついて完成しました
こ
これ長すぎでしょ混ぜカーでフック俺は姉んとこにモノがあっても取れるでしょ
6本
[音楽]
ん今日見てねまあこれだけでかいマジックハンドがあれば
モードにものがあってもねを一緒にとれるわけなんでね
早速順序をとってみよう10早速にオレンジジュースを寝取ってみようと思います
ほらあんなとこにを連日女性があるじゃろいくどいけど純正とるからね
ん
see you 激暑たいん
[音楽]
ん
twitter
これでしばらく
お箸には困りません